[Music]
in 2017 the administrative agencies of
the federal government which many call
the administrative state issued over
3,000 rules and regulations this sounds
like a lot but they have done that in
every year since 1993 a total of over
100,000 rules complying with all these
rules is estimated to cost two trillion
dollars each year more than the total
taxes paid annually by US businesses and
individuals Congress and now President
Trump have tried to stanch this flow but
with little success these efforts have
failed because the courts have not done
what the framers of the Constitution
expected they were supposed to narrowly
interpret the laws that give agencies
their rulemaking Authority but for many
years the courts have allowed the
agencies to interpret the scope of their
own powers the Supreme Court with a
conservative majority will have an
opportunity to change this system and
rein in the administrative state the
question is whether after years of
neglect it will take this important step
to learn more about my take on the
administrative state check out the link
to my book judicial fortitude in the
description below and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI